[Music]
hey guys have you ever gone camping with
a couple of friends and then you go to
bed you're tired you sleep and then
suddenly you hear this noise this bear
growling you wake up only to realize
that it's just one of your friends
that's just snoring so loudly and man we
get a few different types of snoring
like the blower
[Music]
the whistler
the sucker
the growler
and the lumberjack
now i can go on and on here and then
yeah it's funny to talk about this now
but it's not funny when you're really
tired and you just want to get some
sleep
but you can't get some sleep because
someone is snoring or else worse
you are the one snoring keeping
everybody awake including yourself
you've seen those guys who snore so loud
that they sometimes wake themselves up
with their own snoring
so can you do something about it well
that's what i'm going to talk about in
this video let's get to it
alright guys so what exactly are the
causes of snoring well snoring is more
common in men than in women and
if you are obese if you are overweight
now let's take a look at some other
causes as well
number two
a block nose of course you get this from
a cold allergy or a deviated septum
[Music]
number 3
a bad sleeping position have you ever
noticed when you look at someone who is
snoring
and when they lie in their back they
snore a lot more and you kind of just do
this
so they would turn on this side and then
they would actually snore a lot less
number four
a bad pillow strange but true if you use
a bad pillow that is too soft or too big
you will also sleep in a bad position
that might cause you to snore
number five
weak muscles in your tongue and your
throat this usually happens when you are
really relaxed when you sleep deep and
you kind of your tongue and your throat
kind of collapses in your airways and
then you snore
number six
alcohol and drugs this is a strange one
isn't it well it also relaxes you too
much
causing you to snore
number seven
big and bulky throat tissue this can
actually happen to kids as well and this
comes back to being overweight being
obese because then you have these large
tonsils and adenoids which make you
snore
number eight is smoking
shocking but true smoking can make you
snore a lot more
so now that you know some of the causes
of snoring how do you get rid of it well
before i tell you if you like my channel
so far before i forget please remember
to subscribe and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of our future videos i would really love
the support
[Music]
so the treatments for snoring well let's
look at the lifestyle things that you
can actually change the first thing that
you can change if you are overweight is
to lose weight
just live a healthy lifestyle i have a
lot of videos on my channel that can
help you out with it and the same goes
for poor unhealthy lifestyle choices
like using drugs and drinking too much
why don't you quit
think about your family think about
yourself quit for your family and for
yourself have that self-respect to
really start to take care of yourself
and your body you gotta think about your
future don't waste your life
and then if you find yourself if you
wake up in the middle of the night and
you realize hey i'm sleeping on my back
then just turn on your side
and then very important you also need to
maintain a consistent good healthy
sleeping routine because if you don't
sleep enough it can cause your tongue
and throat muscles to relax more when
you do fall asleep and causes you to
snore and then if it is a bad pillow you
can just get a good quality pillow and
if that does not work you can just raise
the head end of your bed just a few
inches just to see if that works now
remember smoking was also one of the
causes so
stop smoking stop
now let's look at a few other options
some people use nasal strips what's that
well they are nasal strips that you can
stick to the bridge of your nose that
will help you to widen your nostrils
then if that doesn't work you can also
try oral appliances it's like a plastic
that you put in your mouth and it keeps
your airways open by moving your tongue
and your jaw and then there's also
something called a cpap machine cpap
that actually helps people with sleeping
problems but it can also help you with
snoring by blowing air into your airways
now if you've tried all of this and it
doesn't work you're still snoring and
your wife is getting angry at you or
your family
then you can try a last resort and that
is surgery but you need to go and see
your doctor about that because there's a
few different surgeries that they can
try now if you want more tips health
tips and also self-improvement tips
watch these playlists here and i'll see
you there and always remember before you
go life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys